taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking hiya taste buddies
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds
and our first ever non-food battle on
the show or non-food related battle
because fork versus spoon was food
related but not edible items
today
we bring you the first in this in the in
the bigger world we are stepping into on
this show where we are now going to be
this is just going to be epic battles of
all sorts not just fight not just food
anymore epic battles of all sorts and
today we launch it off with
people always want to see us eat the
food we're like no no no we're not going
to eat the food you don't want to hear
us on the mic eating the food it's dead
air it's going to be gross well let us
introduce you to
need versus alcohol
where we will do them
all right i obviously have team boos
i obviously am team marjuan
let me explain something to you before
we started this
is so good
oh my god
right before we started we had a big
internal debate because
we wanted we were trying to figure out
what to start off with first because we
wanted something pretty polarizing
we agreed on this
but joe wanted to call it pod versus
booze and we typed it out and i was
about to send them like wait
who calls this who calls it pot versus
booze anymore there's nobody you have
you have alcohol on your chin you sloppy
drunk oh i do yeah you like nobody calls
it pot nobody's called it pot since like
the 70s the 80s
pot versus
you're a booze hound that's why
you you're an old school uh your vices
uh you know are are old school you know
no smoking pot isn't that i mean right
now i think like i guess you're right
people said weed
yeah well we didn't want to call an
episode pop booze because like people
search more for weed and we want more
people to see it weed alcohol so people
aren't going to be throwing pot into the
into the google season you're confusing
pot with grass though grass is a really
good 70s grass is even worse than pop a
pot is not like i don't remember the
last time i referred to marijuana as pot
at all as a matter of fact it's a good
point the only thing that i refer to it
now outside of weed i don't really say
marijuana is
possibly if i'm distinguishing between
an edible or oil or whatever i'll say
like a flower but like
but
that is i hate when people say that but
but i don't have flower yeah flower we
culture is no no no no
[Music]
shut up keith is not
so stupid
i don't call it keef at all isn't keith
the substance i'm not making fun of yes
you're making fun of all no no but i
don't say can i have flour at all i only
use it when i know that it's going to
tran like that i need to communicate to
someone and that's the way they
understand
i would literally have to say do you
have the parts that aren't
that aren't broken apart yeah you ask
them for pot you would ask them for pot
yeah a piece do you have a piece of pot
yeah
i will never again i flower is new to me
somebody already posted me smoking weed
on getting dug with eye
all right
one of the one of the things i want to
say before we even start though is do us
a small favor so we've noticed sometimes
that people are putting the poll results
in the responses and um
please don't do that because uh we go to
the phones at the end of an episode and
we don't want to see the result before
we get we need to see the results so if
you are a real troop buddy you wouldn't
do that thank you sal's argument wheat
is more enjoyable joe's argument the
best alcohol is better than the best
sweet
i think he got it mixed up i think
wait don't you always say that
am i not remembering i thought you
always say the best of is better than
the best
i don't know i don't know all i know is
that weed's better than alcohol we're
already and i come from the alcohol can
wait what's that one say in there where
i'm on the couch
what is that joe refreshing the feed at
night to try to get the extra point five
percent for the third week
what is that a picture of it's a cover
of my second album my second comedy
album glad to know you're a fan
is that the name of the album no i know
i was doubling down on how much i didn't
know all right oh i see
researchers say that alcohol causes more
damage to the brain than marijuana does
well that's just in my favor right at
the top yeah and by the way researchers
you're wrong all right
because uh every guy i know that drinks
you know hey man maybe he's a little
ornery before he has his first pop of
the day but he's he knows where he needs
to be and what time he needs to be there
every person smokes a lot of pot it's
like oh yeah dude i'm getting to it i'm
getting to it sure stress i'm not
talking about the characteristics of the
people
i'm talking about the actual substance
remember that yeah
yeah um no babe look i'm i want to tell
you something here i
not only do i
am i coming from an alcohol camp where
i've dr i've indulged and drank alcohol
and i know alcohol well i owned a bar i
managed a bar i worked in that industry
for about 10 years
i i've spent my life a portion of my
life around alcohol i did not smoke weed
until the end of 2000 i mean
on a regular semi-regular basis until
the end of 2017. prior to the no sorry
17. you went down the tubes late in life
huh eight maybe actually 18 18. 2018 was
when you tried weeds no no
when i started doing it semi-regularly
prior to that in my life i may have
smoked weed less than 20 times
in 40.
let me come out of the gate let me just
come out of the gate with the thing i
hate most about weed okay
i'll get into all those other
shortcomings in a bit but right out of
the gate what i hate i hate how accepted
weed is
in the minute to minute lifestyle of
every single day of the week it drives
me crazy how many people i know
drive their car
head though just drive their car
while smoking weed smoke weed right
before they drive the car whatever if i
did could you imagine if i was driving
you guys around and i pulled out a beer
and cracked it and started drinking it
you'd be like what are you doing pull
over this is crazy
almost not you yeah i i was gonna say
like i wouldn't want to get in the car
with anyone else
we got friends
we have friends to do it you know we do
right i know we do i have a lot of
friends that you'll just be driving
they'll just pull out weed and start
smoking it or they'll be like before we
go let me just take a hit really quick
and it's like why is that okay i know
people that show up to work high and as
long as they do a good job their bosses
don't care could you imagine pulling a
bottle i mean except since 1955 or mad
men whenever the hell that took place
pulling a bottle of whiskey out of your
destroy work people be like call the
authorities right we've got a problem on
our hands right now i just hate the
acceptance of weed versus alcohol
alcohol is still
even though it's way more legal and has
been for longer it's for some reason
more demon eyes than marijuana i don't
know why do you believe that i
absolutely do i absolutely top 10 drunk
hecklers get owned i mean look we're
comics right what comics
now this i'll back you on okay yeah who
would you rather have in your audience a
room full of drunks or a room full of
people that are high i can tell you can
i drop the mic right now i can can i go
do you want to do you want 200 people
bent over with tears coming out of the
face or do you want 200 hecklers buddy
yeah i got news for you i'll take the
drunk city day of the week and here's
why i have done pot shows yeah where the
audience is doing nothing but smoking
pot well and it is the worst set you've
ever glad i didn't do that because
they're like they're like all i'm like
dabs and all that stupid [ __ ] they put
it now that you know like yeah this is
weed that they turned into paper and
then you blind it up whatever the [ __ ]
it is yeah anyway and there it forget it
dude it's you're talking you might as
well be talking to bear walls i don't
know dude
you at least have a fighting chance to
wrangle them and ride the wall i don't
care if i never have to speak to a drunk
birthday party or a drunk
what do you call it when you get married
that's the right party
please put this guy up here look at this
this is your people right here again i
am not talking about your
college white guy with dreads that dab
but let's i'm not talking about the
profiles of the people that consistently
everyone has everyone smokes booze and
weeds i'm talking about how booze and
weed make you feel i'm talking about the
boobs on the weeds that's so much worse
behind the worst the worst real quick
and then we'll get off people behind it
let's talk where's the words who would
you rather hang out with that kid with
the put him up here pimp this this kid
or
or a wino
i mean pull up a wino i'd rather hang
out with the wino smells like a toilet
i'd rather go with
what's wrong with their faces
what is that it's like an altered photo
oh
i'd rather hang out with these guys
they're gonna leave me alone dude out of
my way one of these guys can we just get
into the actual can we can we stop the
peripheral stuff because i there's a lot
to talk about with weed and booze okay i
came from it i love getting drunk i used
to you know i like getting a little tiny
one on a little bit getting a little
lubricated taking the edge off a little
bit of a social help i like it i like it
it has some pluses but it has way more
minuses alcohol booze has way more
minuses i believe than weed does
okay i actually hit a point in my life
where i was like i dislike drinking too
much so much
like
you achieve something when you get a
certain amount of drunk but with it
comes headache dehydration
hangover hangover hangover
over
on the hangover
whenever we hang out there's no such
thing as a weed hangover okay oh yes
there is no there's not yes there is not
real yes there is you feel completely
burnt out the next day yes there is no
you still feel kind of high kind of feel
fried you feel fried and you can't judge
reality properly because you're fried i
mean how much no all right i i i don't
really experience any bad effects if i
smoke some weed the next day alcohol if
i
a drink or two past what i normally go
past at this point the next day i am off
i am dehydrated i have the shakes a
little bit i am dead tired i can't
function that's just a light hangover
the ones where you're laying on the
couch
and your head is splitting and the room
is spinning and you're most likely have
to vomit a few times to get it out and
you have to eat something greasy to get
your druthers back and you're not good
until about 10 p.m the next day or maybe
noon two days later that is the worst
feeling in the world i felt it
like college kid hangover right now no
i'm not i mean you go to any bar in new
york city there's a percentage of people
in that bar that are
not those people we're talking about the
way it affects us as you said no but
that's the way booze affects me i'm done
with that i am i have been introduced to
the savior of all saviors what are you
talking about i want to get mellow i
don't want to get hyper i don't want to
get out of control i don't want to make
mistakes i want to not make mistakes
what are you talking about you don't
know what i'm saying we hung out on on
labor day together we drank the entire
day
nonsense i don't say that i don't drink
joe actually the next day i could i get
like that maybe like once a year now
maybe twice a year a national holiday a
big barbecue i drank during the barbecue
next day felt like [ __ ] i don't get that
you're you're insane right you're insane
you are insane you don't do that you
don't do that you're insane you know
what he does you know he does you know
what he does here's what he does he's
right he doesn't drink like that he
drinks like that and smokes pot the
entire time
i have a drink in hand but he's not and
thinks he's not drinking you're drinking
joe you don't know anything joe joe
don't you don't know what i drank that
day you know why because you don't i
look in your shots i looked at your eyes
you weren't even there bro i did the
shots with you when i'm drinking with
you you don't know what's going on you
just see me with a drink you think
everyone's on your level that's a very
common thing for people that like it
is burning your head and you know your
perceptions off you don't know what
you're doing i look at you sometimes and
you can not stand up straight i have a
conversation with you as you sway back
and forth and your eyeballs in your
sockets are ping-ponging around like a
goddamn cartoon listen your birthday i
looked at you your pupils were dilated
this big you were swaying and you were
looking everywhere but at me and we
talked for 10 minutes the next day you
felt like the worst in your life that's
what i'm just saying i'm not saying that
there's not delicious types of food
there's wine there's hard liquor this is
moist
nobody's saying this can't happen with
booze i'm not scoffing at that i'm
scoffing at you saying that you do not
drink that's what i'm scoffing at to
make this argument for weed that you're
making i didn't say i didn't drink i
said i don't get that kind i don't drink
like that not anymore not for years i
hate it and the occasional times that i
do get that way i always regret it and
it makes me re like be like i'm not
doing that again that's why it's like
only every six months it takes that long
for me to be like i just
like just have fun i just let go but i
hate it i absolutely hate it i have a
drink now
with dinner i have a drink now on a you
know at a barbecue or ice-cold beer
whatever but i don't go in hard like
goddamn lmfao with shot shot shot shot
shot shot shots neither do i
i'm not saying you do i'm just saying
okay all i'm trying to say is that right
booze has way more negative outcomes
when you start drinking okay you could
blackout you could make bad choices you
could
[ __ ] out of yourself sure you could
not know where you are absolutely
absolutely in extreme cases
let's talk about that let's talk about
the shortcomings of weed keep smoking
hold on if you keep drinking let's talk
about the shortcomings of weed let's
talk about the bad aspects of weed
full-on panic attacks extreme paranoia
saying stupid [ __ ] because you don't
know what's going on getting an
uncontrollable emotional fits that you
can't give you because you are a very
very occasional smoker
i was just pothead all through college
and into my 20s i smoked pot every day i
stopped smoking it because it turns on
you eventually
you are a neurotic person by trade so if
you're going to take somebody that could
stoke that it's going to happen even the
most hardcore potheads i know okay for
the most part i will say to them
you don't ever get no they go no no no
no i have that 10 minutes where i have
to talk myself down you don't get that
with booze bro you don't have to talk
yourself down too much alcohol equals
ruined life too much weed what is life
okay point taken but here's my point and
dude i'll take that 10 minutes of
i'm a little paranoid versus
night a blackout night of six hours when
you know who you saw what you said
you're talking about wait a second wait
a second like you're talking some people
wake up in bed with you like i sleep
with this person you're talking about an
extreme blackout case of a drunk you're
not talking about the average i'm
talking about the risks versus the
rewards if you if you continue to drink
throughout a night
you are done it's a hospital visit you
are drunk you are blackout someone's
saying
you just smoke weed throughout the whole
night just get more chill oh please i'm
so tired of this pothead argument
of weed is the truth man
god put it here for us man it helps us
relax man booze
makes you aggro dude okay it wires you
up no booze is the party son booze is
time to dance booze is let's go booze
just set them up and talk about that
booze is sweaty people yelling in your
ear because they don't understand the
volume of their voice spitting on you
every time they enunciate loud talking
holding on because
to talk to a pothead as he spins you in
circles and doesn't understand what a
god what a basic concept is i'd like to
have a conversation with a potted way
more than i would have drunk so i talked
to you recently hi
and i tried to explain to you how great
was it i tried to explain to you how
what was the show that you were asking
me about you spun me around so much i
thought i was high tell me what we were
we were hanging out at our buddy's
basement okay okay
and i was trying to explain to you
we're at q's house yes we're at hugh's
house yes and i i didn't know if we were
allowed to say or not about where we
were i don't know i don't know i don't
know i mean it stands the reason i've
been in this home i mean the jokers you
know you guys limited on a different
level than i did all right no problem
what did i tell you what i was trying to
explain to you how what the hell was it
yeah
and then trying to name the show that
you're thinking of but with alcohol you
punch in a straight
trying to explain to you how you get
into a ballroom
not you but my point is this is all
things and here's orbit
and you don't go home and you know what
because with reward comes risk you want
to go out you want to have a fun night
you want to have an electric night you
want to have an eventful night you got
to take a few risks oh instead let's
smoke pot and sink into the couch and
watch these six youtube videos for the
seven thousandth time in a row if you're
hitting up that gun maybe if you're
hitting up indica like well but he could
have sativa and go out socially please
please there's no difference you could i
can continue to smoke so a person can
continue to smoke weed all night long
all they're gonna do is kind of get more
high i drink or i drink all night long
and all that happens is i start to get a
little tired eventually no no no all
that happens is at the end of the night
all that happens is the next day there's
a slew of texts going around it's like
anyone catch derosa last night
no i wouldn't know who the guy who
passed out and slept in a bar and then
ordered burger king after yeah yeah
let's talk about i know it was you let's
talk about that recently you've gotten
so drunk you slept in the bar like it
was your shelter from home no you stayed
the owner of the bar said you can crash
here i'm gonna crash
because you drank to you slept in a
business in a booth overnight right
because you drank too much right i mean
i smoke weed you know what i do i take
the long walk home because i'm enjoying
life
i'm taking oh shut up this 10 minutes
there's ten minutes of anxiety but it's
followed by about two hours of yo you
know what
it is what it is and i like that it
calms you down
alcohol does not calm you down alcohol i
like being socially lubricated i
understand a drink i think alcohol is
good i still drink alcohol if i put it
up
if i put it out if i put it up against
weed where i am at in my life right now
weed this is what it is a pleasurable
experience what i hate about you never
go south
this is what i hate about this is this
is what i hate about the weed
enthusiasts they talk about it as if
it's this mature coming-of-age thing as
if you have to evolve into weed i'm
talking about my experience and where i
am in my life right now experience
really i only like really started
smoking and when they really started to
get spiritually accessible i never
bought it from a drug dealer i didn't
know how to roll it i didn't my
experience with me was this i smoked it
all the time and i thought i'm a drug
dealer i thought all the positive things
you thought about it okay i've never
talked to a drug dealer i thought all
the positive things you thought about
weed for many many many years and i
loved it so much i loved nothing more
than getting high on my buddies and
listening to music or and discovering
new things and then
the next day realizing the record sucked
you know did you ever listen to pink
floyd sober not a good time not a good
time this is a food podcast originally
is it not yeah okay but wait wait let me
finish my point go ahead okay and i will
tell you something weed is a
psychoactive drug
it is a hallucinogenic albeit a mild one
it will i don't know
it absolutely is considered a
hallucinogenic pimp it can it can and
will turn on you
booze i'm not saying will not turn on
you but it will turn on you in a way
where you know where you're at with it
booze will turn on you where you go no
you spiral out of control on booze you
do not spiral out everything never had a
full-on never had an hour-long panic
attack on booze had it on weed many
times many times
sneaks up on you if you know if you
don't know how to drink it it does which
is most people oh stop yeah oh you stop
yeah you stop do you know how to drink
it please
do you do i know how to would you
consider someone who knows how to drink
booze then why do you still have the
situations that i'm talking about right
now if you know how to control yourself
what situations when you get blackout
drunk when you sleep in a bar i don't
want you to blackout drunk i'm two on
two occasions on two special occasions
my birthday labor day about me drinking
okay my birthday my birthday and one
other time so that you're citing so it's
okay for you to do it on special
occasions so when i said it was a
special case on labor day oh you just
were like oh you drove all the times out
of okay my birthday there was a special
occasion sure you got [ __ ] faced all
right
you know but i walked out of this not
drunk okay fine it was my birthday sue
me it was my birthday but your birthday
is
like a lot
what do you mean you drink a lot on my
birthday no but you you're a drinker i
mean we live in a social event you're
assuming guys who's the new yorker would
i need to cite right now do i need to
cite the non-special occasion where you
were barfing into a trash can do i need
to decide i don't even know what this is
you don't know what it is
yeah you know what it is there it is
that was that was the drunkest i've been
in probably i'll i'll probably say
three years okay okay how about uh how
about when we were recently in a pool
together and you had to stop playing
beer pong because you said i can't play
anymore i'm [ __ ] up i didn't say i was
[ __ ] up i said i can't drink anymore
i'm too full i ca
i played all day long in the sun i
didn't want to join and i wasn't drunk i
just didn't want to i didn't want to
feel lousy you weren't drunk so you
could have driven a car at that point no
buddy but i was not i was in full
control i just drank i don't i don't
like drinking i mean out
listen to what you just did you brought
up a time when i said i've had enough to
drink i'm fine i don't want to drink
anything that's not what you were doing
how is that a strike against me no
that's not what you were doing we played
i was done i did not want to drink any
more beer it gets me dehydrated
i don't get what you're saying just
because i was like i don't want to play
anymore
so i said so i said i don't want to
drink anymore i've had enough and that's
a strike against me if anything you
should be like you should use it against
me to be like you're able to cut
yourself off when would because that's
if that's if that is your interpretation
of that event then fine but my point i'm
you're you're naming things that go in
like when that happened to me when i got
drunk and had to throw up into a garbage
can i hate that i it snuck up on me i
hadn't eaten that day we talked like it
was six years ago and it wasn't a
special occasion it was a night no i was
we were performing oh
so that counts especially no no but i
mean like come on that's why i had a
drink to begin with i was in a club i
was in a club and i had a drink like i'm
not i don't even understand what we're
arguing about bro i'm arguing for weed
versus boosh you're like bringing up
every three years when i drink i don't
know what you're doing what do you mean
i i hate that that drunk that i got and
that's why i'm on the side of weed i
could have went there that night and
smoked weed all night and i would have
been just i just think your weed
argument is [ __ ] i'd like to talk to
you about babble
babble is a uh a language learning app i
love it when you're traveling to a
destination where you don't know the
language it can be challenging to
accomplish even the simplest of tasks
tasks thankfully there's babble number
one uh selling language learning app we
use it i use it i know i do uh they have
bite-sized lessons to help you learn new
language skills they could usually apply
in the real world you could actually do
that you need babble because i've gone
to other countries where english was not
the primary language or even secondary
language and i would always try
communicating with others through my
mind
[Laughter]
it doesn't work it doesn't i tried
drawing a series of pictures that was
always problematic that's very
antiquated yeah but i mean it's anything
from reading a menu to to having the
proper greeting you know for that
country 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn on the go uh you
can choose from 14 different languages
spend spanish french italian german
they have a speech recognition
technology that helps you improve your
pronunciation and accent which i need
the worst
i think you really like it a lot of
people are always telling me oh i wish i
hadn't learned a second language i'd
like to learn the second language i
don't have the time i have the money
this is on your phone in your on your
time it right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
so go to babel.com and use the promo
code taste buds that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
[Music]
and the promo code is taste buds babble
language for life man
i love busy i i had a barbecue yesterday
yeah and i had burgers and dogs and i
had a whole bunch of vizzies
and at the end of the day i felt
empowered
because i loaded my
bod up with antioxidants and vitamin c
that i otherwise wouldn't have had if i
was drinking a spiked seltzer that
didn't think of these things i agree and
i will tell you something and i swear to
you i'm not just saying this
you know i've run the gamut of the spike
celtics you know i know you run the game
now i'm not saying there aren't brands
out there i like i know you're not
saying that there's other brands that
you don't like busy busy tastes better
yeah
then
i would say i pitted against any heart
cells are out there i really do think it
tastes better it came into my life hard
you know it's my life hard and i prefer
it and coming out with a lemonade now
too which i'm happy about and it's as
strong as a beer it's five percent it's
only 100 cows there's only less than a
gram of real cane sugar in it and i mean
listen to some of the flavors dude
pineapple mango black cherry lime
raspberry tangerine i mean they're just
so exciting this is it baby i love it
upgrade your hard sell to the visi to
find out where you can purchase vizzy go
to vizzyhardseltzer.com
tastebuds that's vizi v-i-z-z-y
hard seltzer.com slash tastebuds must be
21 or older
that's what i'm saying you have yet to
say a thing to me that tells me that
that alcohol is better than wheat
you said you said 10 minutes of anxiety
and a groggy day the next day
because you're barreling over the things
i'm saying just because you've never had
an hour-long panic attack where you
thought you were going to drop dead on
weed literally dropped dead i had to
leave a [ __ ] concert because i ate an
edible a
a 15 milligram edible i had to leave the
concert because i thought the room was
closing in on me and i was going to die
okay that's like someone you're you're
in there you're bringing up a point of
someone that is akin to someone getting
alcohol poisoning oh no
you didn't know what you were doing
you're an idiot you took way too much
edible and you paid the price all right
way too much 15 milligrams i'm a college
kid i'm like yeah if you don't do it
what do you mean of course you how is
that not
you are sometimes you get me so upset
you
you you contradict yourself from
[Applause]
no it's not the same thing
the most common experience with each
okay so i'm talking about how many times
a lot you know how many people i know
that say i can't smoke weed it makes me
crazy it makes me paranoid i don't know
anybody that's no no i take that back i
take that back i'm not going to speak
i'm not going to speak in generalities i
know a lot of people now i know a lot of
people that say i can't smoke weed it
makes me crazy it makes me paranoid i
know people who are heavy mushroom and
acid users that say weed is the devil it
is the devil okay okay i know people
nobody's losing their families over weed
nobody's losing their job over weed okay
nobody's losing their life over weed
okay
all the girls i know that say they had
to dump their boyfriends because all he
did was sit on the couch and hit his
bong and play video games all day okay
okay go talk to all the people that have
[ __ ] okay you ain't proving [ __ ]
okay let's go to the regular you pukey
in the trash can is me having a panic
attack okay so let's go to the i'm keep
trying to go to the to the most basic
experience for each thing i smoke a half
a joint or a joint i chill out that
night okay
nothing's happening to me
odds are if you're gonna drink you're
either gonna be able to stop or you're
not it's way more common for someone who
is indulging in just one drink or two
drinks that night to end up getting
drunk when they didn't want to and then
i'm having a shitty day the next day
this way more common for the average
alcohol user to end up with a bad
experience from alcohol than it is for
the average reed smoker
with a bad
experience to that i would say this i
will 100 agree with you that the
immediate hangover of alcohol is far
more robust than the immediate hangover
or effects of weed but i will not stand
here and let you say that continual and
habitual weed use does not have a
long-term horrible effect on a human
being it does it makes people forgetful
it means holy [ __ ] why are you going
back to continued and habitual we don't
need to argue we don't need to argue i
thought i was gonna die i was so high
and he's gonna palm my stomach let's go
back to the way that most people
experience these things that's what i'm
talking about most people i know that
smoke weed smoke it habitually
that's what i'm talking about so do you
sometimes i feel like i'm going crazy do
you feel like i'm going you think our
friends do you just go back to the most
relatable form of this oh do you think
our friends that smoke weed uh on every
night are potheads yes okay well that's
not how i would that's not how earlier
what is a pothead i would say around the
clock pot smokers i don't think somebody
that has a drink every night is an
alcoholic i don't think somebody that
hits weed every night is is a pothead i
think if you i mean that's really the
term that's really exactly the
definition all right so you drink every
day you're an alcoholic you smoke every
day you're probably if you have two
glasses of wine every day you're an
alcoholic
yeah actually textbook you probably are
although i get it
consuming seven come on guys what are we
talking about here seven drinks per week
then then sal and i are both alcoholics
right so then so so your opinion is
better than the national institute on
alcohol abusing your holy spirit these
are the people that dedicated that so
you think you're not
an alcoholic you agree with that you're
an alcoholic no i don't i don't have
seven or more drinks a week no [ __ ]
way insane
no i don't
no i don't swear to god hand to god hand
to god
joe joe
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute maybe this is an
intervention maybe this is an
intervention for you you believe that
every week i consistently have more than
seven drinks a week i think you're out
of your
gourds
if there's a week where we hang and i
drink one night seven drinks that's the
one night
most i will i i'm telling you to your
face right now i would say
if you average my drink consumption over
the course of a year and average i don't
even there's
weeks that i don't drink weeks that i
don't even have a drink you you're
insane
so you think i'm having you think i'm
having four at least two times in a week
i'm having four drinks a night
you just said you have a drink with
dinner very often that's seven days in a
week if you have a glass of wine every
night with dinner that i would do a
glass of wine every night with dinner i
have i enjoy having wine with dinner
usually if i'm out i just hate so you
just you just make [ __ ] up i don't make
[ __ ] up you just put yourself i hang out
with you every week oh my god joe my
goodness i hang out with you every week
right right i hang out with you every
week yeah and when i hang out with you
every week every week if i if you see me
at the club do what do i have if i go
there
i've seen you have tricks right yeah a
drink right okay and then i go home
right and then let's say the next year
that's more like two three wait let's
say dude let's say i do two nights of
stand up a week
maybe one night let's say i do three
that's average one night i don't drink
two nights i have one and i have two one
and i have one that's three you're
telling me i consistently have over
seven a week i don't know seven at least
seven i didn't say overseas i don't
i don't
just because you have seven a day
i don't have seven a day okay well you'd
if i was you right now and you said that
i'd be like
what
yes you do the way you flipped out is
insane i don't have over seven drinks a
week so i do not over seven it's six
seven
my point is i don't average seven drinks
a week i don't i don't do that anymore
i'm i began this argument telling you
that i used to do that and years ago i
said i'm not doing this like this
anymore now i just can't i just okay all
right listen you're gonna make the
argument
you you wanna here's what you wanna
here's what go back and check the tape
all you've done in this episode is argue
anything but
weed no the good
because when i make a long-term argument
about weed you go oh that's not true
that's not true it's like it is true
stop acting like people that smoke pot
smoke it once a week stop acting like
you smoke it once a week people that
smoke i didn't i didn't say that so you
just said
i said habitually that means a few times
every week that means it's part of your
regular life and i said to you why don't
we bring it to the people and give them
the argument the way most people can
relate to it every once in a while most
people really i got this every once in a
while some dreams that like
almost every single day you're not going
to speak in generalities gotcha great
okay
shouting generality
you and every other pot smoker i know
when somebody breaks out a blunt or a
joint at the club i have never seen any
of you say no i don't want to hit that
right now okay never ever ever ever ever
that's not true at all
not true at all just like i always say
i'll do it for the last two years i
haven't done that because of covid so if
i haven't done it in 24 months [ __ ]
another thing is that you can't equate
someone being like do you want a hit of
this and a pot smoker taking a hit of
weed that's like me telling you you
drink every day if i saw you go can i
taste that margarita no seven no no no
no no no no you drink a full tree a head
of pie is equal to what is equal to two
shots i would say equal to two shots
changes
because you smoke so much pot you don't
even realize how strong it hit a pot you
are insane you are insane
i can smoke a half a joint because you
smoke a lot of weed habitually it
doesn't feel like it's not equal to two
shots it's tolerant
there's a tolerance with weed just like
there is with booze great yeah but what
does that have to do with the argument
the argument is you told me to bring up
a shortcoming of weed i said habitual
long-term pot hues is a thing that
people think doesn't have any effect on
them when it does okay i said that a
hangover with booze is more robust and
in your face the next day with immediate
effects however the long-term effects of
pot on your mental state are worse i
disagree
i think i think alcoholism will kill you
before weedism okay kill you i said the
worst on your health you're mentally
[ __ ] living worse on your worse on
your heart worse on your weight okay
okay
cigarettes are worse for you than any of
them but they won't affect your mental
state that's my point you getting fresh
with me i'm getting fresh with you with
hellofresh america's number one meal kit
kind of getting fresh that i like all
right you know hellofresh we talk about
it all the time meal kit to your door
save money on groceries save money on
the restaurants make it more convenient
if you're on the go if you got kids if
you're working late if you're trying to
learn more about cooking okay you get
all the ingredients pre-packaged to your
door it's a wide variety of meals folks
holiday season is coming up school's
about to start again you're going to be
running around you're going to be able
you're going to want to be able to make
some decent meals for yourself or maybe
for your family that you can enjoy that
aren't going to take a ton of time
that's what hellofresh is here to do
they're going to give you the
flexibility you need to customize your
order on the app within minutes easily
change your delivery day your food
preferences your plan size or skip a
week if you want to
i mean it's that convenient and there's
not many products on here that are good
for the single fella or gal and a loaded
up family you understand what i'm saying
or a working professional this this
this benefits everybody it really does i
agree so go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds14
and use the code tastebuds one for why
because you're going to get up to 14
free meals including free shipping if
you ration those 14 meals you could live
like six months on that i agree go to
hellofresh.com
buds one four and use that code taste
buds one for for 14 free meals including
free
shipping hellofresh america's number one
meal kit
hey taste buddies want to talk to you
about candid uh uh they're pretty new on
our show but we love them and uh there's
a specialist for just about everything
right joe yes when my car breaks down i
go to the mechanic when there's a
problem with my shower i call the
mechanic
plumber you mean no i call the mechanic
so when you want your to get your uneven
crooked teeth fixed you see an
orthodontist they're specialists that's
what sets candid the invisible
comfortable and removable aligners above
the rest you can book an appointment at
a candid studio near you and do
everything from the comfort and
convenience of your own home i love how
much stuff you can do from home now the
average candid treatment is just six
months you'll see you'll start seeing
results way before then all right costs
thousands of dollars less than
traditional braces candid can help you
get the straighter brighter smile you've
always wanted right now you can get
started from home for just twenty
dollars with a candid starter kit you
can also get the teeth whitening kit for
free by the way you can yes or you can
book an appointment at a candid studio
near you go to candidco.com
tastebuds and use the code tastebuds
that's candidco.com
tastebuds use the code tastebuds take
advantage of a limited time offer for
our listeners for a 20 starter kit
candidco.com
taste buds and that's for your liner
treatment and a free teeth waiting kit
code taste buds
a long-term habitual drinker is way
worse off than a long-term habitual weed
smoker yes or no
no
all right you just you just went you no
you you you're freaking out you're
drinking your whole life crashing you
didn't die you crashed like a lot of old
drinkers yeah all right you know a lot
of old drinkers who's in worse shape a
person that's
seeing the end of a bottle every day or
the per person that's smoking
a bottle every day that's your who's
worse off a person that has five drinks
a day or something according to yourself
who's worse off
half a drink a day or a person has two
glasses of wine today doctors will tell
you the person who has two glasses of
wine is actually healthier
from a heart stance i'll go i'll go
right by i'll go right by your sliding
scale who's worse off a person that
drinks five drinks a day or a person
that smokes a joint a day five drinks is
not equivalent to a joint that's not
fair
you you you didn't just say that you
just told me one puff of weed is equal
to two shots i do one puff of weed i am
[ __ ] up then if i drank a six pack
what you just told me was a puff of weed
was equal to two shots which means a
joint would be equal to about 30 shots
in the next sentence i gave you five
drinks for the whole joint and you said
that's not a fair comparison you
literally shattered what you just said
right okay fine fine i'll give it to you
mentally mentally or physically
mentally the pot person way way way way
way
physically the boost person absolutely i
i don't know joe
why are we arguing also let's talk about
the benefits i'm sorry i we talked about
smoke weed you it helps you relax it
helps you relax make sure that you
[ __ ] finish now you let me finish
we does help you relax
you're really good
medicinal weed medicinal you ever hear a
doctor go oh i'm so sorry you're
suffering and you're in pain why don't
you go home and have some
ginger absolutely absolutely no they
don't i mean no we drink two glasses of
wine every day to help your good
cholesterol medicinal
anxiety it might give you anxiety
weed gives more people relaxation than
it does give people anxiety i believe
weed helps you sleep weed helps you
relax okay help me opens your mind up
okay art comes from weed what some of my
greatest ideas and some of my greatest
jokes and bits i thought of okay guess
what some of your absolute worst also
that is a 50 50 split in you know but it
opens my
i'm a writer i'm a writer i'm a
published writer some of my greatest
writing came when i drank a bottle of
wine in front of my computer what does
that have to do with it i'm talking
about some of the benefits of weed it
has everything to do with it okay i i
can't even make general we're agreed
upon points about we you're arguing
things that are common that everyone
would agree with okay it's insane okay
you're insane i started to say before
this is a start off as a food podcast
okay yeah
weed enhances food alcohol does not
[ __ ] wine enhances every meal
christopher hitchens every food ever not
in a way in a way that all food tastes
better with wine not in a way that red
wine complements uh you know a steak or
you know a fish coming i'm talking about
i'm talking about smoke weed and eat
anything give me your shoes oh you think
that's put some salt on no i think it's
one of the benefits of weed you think
that's a benefit that you'll smoke weed
and go you know what i want to dip a
whole bag of ruffles into a [ __ ]
candle marshmallow obviously i don't
think that's a good idea i'm just
proving the point i'm not going to turn
you into a baseball animal that doesn't
know anything better anything if you if
you eat any dish
and you're high it tastes better than
when you're not high that is the benefit
of weed i cannot say that for alcohol i
would disagree i've had plenty of great
drunken meals i've had plenty of great
late-night drunken meals you go out
right you leave a bar you hit a burger
king okay you leave a bar you hit a
diner is there anything better than a
late-night drink
i think what's happening there is you're
very hungry but when you're high and you
eat the right food it's like oh my god
like this is you know how many times
high people say this might be the best
blank i've ever had do you think it's
the best blank they've ever had no it's
the [ __ ] weed that is a benefit of
weed i'm naming benefits of wheat and
you're telling me
it's taking you out of your head okay
it's not a benefit you think it's not a
benefit and then everyone else in the
world
in fact i've always said that one of the
things i hated most about weed was the
munchies because you can't stick to your
diet you can't stick to anything because
you get so ravenously [ __ ] hungry
that you start eating anything you can
get your hands on and then when you come
down you feel terrible about it better
than being face down on the pavement who
the hell has ever been faced out on a
pavement many people oh god you're
talking about i i don't know i don't
know what you want but i don't know what
you want at least i'm not throwing up
from weed
all right sorry talk about grimace we
talked about grimace last episode i mean
like a lot of alcohol is an acquired
taste as well and by the way and by the
way and by the way and this needs to be
pointed out this needs to be pointed out
okay because i know you're just in the
last three years coming into this weed
thing and and it's all nice and
government regulated and you get it nice
and neat and you know what you're
getting
pal i smoked it when you [ __ ] smoked
it you know how much [ __ ] i smoked that
had lysol dumped on it because the drug
dealer wanted to lie to you that it was
good weed do you know how much [ __ ] you
did you wanted
moonshine out of a tub what do you want
dude you you breathe
was so incredibly unsafe for so long
it's only now become safe and now
everybody's like it's so great do you
want to do like a back to the future
episode where we all get weed versus
alcohol in 1982 because i'm talking
about now because this is when we're
alive right
so yeah i'm telling you something i'm
just everything you everything you
brought up this whole episode either
four blues or four weed is so off topic
it's not just the benefit the pluses in
mind
i don't think uh is there a weed
anonymous
there should be is it twelve steps
forward it should be this is my point of
the double standard wheat everybody
thinks weed is this harmless thing it's
not it burns people out it fries
people's brains people become completely
unreliable and spacey and whenever on
wheat and everybody acts like it's just
this fun little thing that could be a
downside to some people who use weed the
wrong way 100 if you're equating it to
booze
everything you just said is way more
applicable to booze and weed that's not
true sal that's not true yes alcoholism
is is much more of a role
here's why it's more of a record problem
because it's been legal for a lot longer
i promise you this track the weed usage
over the next
50 60 70 80 90 years okay that that
alcohol has been legal in this country
yeah and you're you're going to see a
whole different outcome of statistics
when we so now we're going to see a
whole different thing fair point i'll
start tracking weed for the next 60 70
80 and 90 years oh you know i'm right
though you know i'm right you know i'm
right i i don't believe you are actually
i truly don't you don't i don't i don't
believe you i think that there are
pitfalls to both and i think the
pitfalls and you think way outweighed
the pitfalls i think it's evident and i
think everyone would share that opinion
and you think in your three year tenure
of smoking weed that you have done that
you have the statistics to match the 90
years in this country that alcohol has
been prevalently readily available and
and and legal no i know i i don't have
my personal user experience you don't
think weed being illegal has something
to do with the fact that we don't have
statistics on how damaging it could be
you don't think that has anything to do
with it that there's never been really
any studies done on weed because it's
been every drug it's every drug come on
you're here to legalize drug things all
the time tax it make it work for us make
it not illegal you'll you'll clear out
the problems you'll clear up all the bad
batches of stuff that are killing people
okay this argument all the time it's not
just for weed but it is what it is i've
been drinking alcohol for 25 years i've
been smoking weed for three i have
enough experience with both you do i
like alcohol i drink it i ran i i ran
myself
around at least 70. yeah okay
10 000 gallons of bad booze
wow the people were dropping dead in the
resorts yeah yeah that was like not that
long ago right
booze resorts shut down operations
regulation regulars recently visited
nearly three dozen
restaurants what was bad about it what
happened this was a this was this was a
bad manufacturing process so it's like
it's almost like an e coli lettuce
situation
all right this was this was a hell of a
heated episode this was rough that was
just like a serious argument not even
jokes
i know
i'm upset about it i'm i'm i'm upset i'm
a little upset i know me too i'm a
little upset i mean there was actually i
didn't expect it there was no jokes
there i didn't exp no it wasn't
lighthearted we just got into a fight
i'm too high for this episode
are you high yeah look at this pimp's
showing up to work high
i love it [ __ ] on the porch that's how
it was that's why he's inside hear that
laugh look at him he's radiating
sunshine look at that man he's a happy
man i'm happy i took one puff of this
didn't it did nothing to me am i am i
like oh my god there's one puppy i drank
about four of those right yeah i know i
know that's why you're acting the way
you want you can't maintain a good
argument
look at how you're acting off of one
point i'm in the pocket
we
has done nothing to me let's pick a
winner this is our this is our winner
today nick alexander says no one is ever
going to pay someone 18 years of child
to support from getting too high love it
aren't you a bull but funny follow nick
at
teddy underscored the jet
uh teddy and the jets all right folks
let's just go to the teddy
teddy teddy and the chance
yes oh
yes
yes
yes
someday
when i'm awfully low
when the world is cold you will feel a
glow just thinking of you
and the way you look tonight you know
what that is frank sinatra big booze
enthusiast
didn't sing about pot did he
pot be elected
wow weed loses oh by two percent
disguise i needed my my badass was too
busy being high yeah
like bro you see this you're gonna we
gotta vote on this exactly exactly
all
that means that a two percent margin
means that we dominated you because the
people that are high are not are not
motivated to to vote
no but that doesn't affect your brain
there's nothing everything is better on
weeds you could have been better on weed
man
i don't know why you kicked into the guy
from freedom rock but all right because
i'm being a [ __ ] 17 000 votes
alcohol
is
52.3 to 47.7
so it's
2.3 which is rematch anything under 5 is
rematch territory
i want to do my plugs you're going to do
no i get no we're done i want to do my
plugs it's important to do plugs
please
i love how you just change the rules of
the podcast what i just want to do plugs
bro i'm trying to sell tickets i finally
have four dates on something we didn't
do the songs you invented either did you
guys do them what songs
what oh we didn't we did taste but at
the beginning we forgot to do
b-a-t-t-l-e but maybe just just one for
the audience right now b-a-t-t-l-e
bunch all right
um uh i'm on tour and when is this
coming out
uh let's see maybe if you just smoke so
much pot
hold on hold on let me just check that
you can cut this out
don't cut it out no let it go let
everybody see let everybody see how
great pot is this is what pot looks like
everybody i got two dates i got two
dates for you guys i'm actually doing
with chris distefano october 1st in
baltimore at the lyric and october 29th
at in dorm north carolina at the deepak
uh both are on sale right now at
salvocanocomedy.com and then the guys
and i are on tour the tenderloins.com
for those tickets it's like 50 cities
and they're all on sale right now
come smoke with me i'm not going to plug
the up in smoke tour i'm not going to
plug
because here's why because i follow the
rules
just like with booze i drink illegals
i drink legally
i don't do illegal drugs that they just
shuffle through in the last legislative
process
anyway i still love you
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking